-Thank you for being
in the studio, pal.
There's lots to talk about.
Congrats, first of all,
on being on "Dear Evan Hansen"
and getting crazy good reviews.
You're fantastic.
-Thanks. Thank you so much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We have this big project
we have to talk about,
but first off
I want to say how charming
and cute were your parents.
I just met backstage.
-Yeah. I love them so much.
I'm so happy that they're here!
-Do they come
to all your stuff?
-Yes, all the time.
-They do?
-They're very supportive.
I love them very much.
-I love them.
Now you're doing this new film.
You're about to go to Italy
or no?
Where are you doing this?
-I just came from Italy.
-Okay, and you're
about to do this new film.
-And now I'm going to go
to Australia.
-Australia. Wow.
-Yes.
-And who are playing
your parents in this film?
-George Clooney and Julia
Roberts are playing my parents.
-Yeah, not bad. That's --
That's pretty awesome.
I mean,
are your parents psyched?
They're like,
"This is perfect casting."
-I mean, it is truly. I mean --
But they're also just like,
"Meh. That's cool."
-Really? Really?
They just do that?
-They're just very chill
about it, yeah.
-Last time we talked,
you told me
that you were in a band
with your sister.
-Yes.
-All right? And you're
about to release music.
-We are. We've been working on
an EP for a good while.
We kind of got stopped
because of the pandemic.
But we're releasing new music.
-And the name of your band
with your sister
was Beulahbelle.
-Yes, Beulahbelle
is the current name.
-It's the current name.
Beulahbelle.
-Yes. Beulahbelle. You're having
trouble saying it already.
-I am, yes.
But you want to change it --
-That's why we want
to change it.
No can spell it.
No one can say it.
And we just want
something fresh.
-Fresh.
-Yeah, we just need
something fresh.
And it's also, like, the last
time we can change it, too,
because we've changed it,
like --
This will be the fourth time
we change it.
But this is --
We can't do it anymore.
-We can crack this tonight.
-Oh, you're going to come up --
-Yeah, I'm going to come up
with your name, yeah.
Because it's Kaitlyn Dever.
What's your sister's name?
-Maddie Dever.
-We can't be, like,
the Dever Sister.
That's not gonna work.
-Deeves.
-Deeves?!
People do call me "Deeves."
That's -- That's good.
[ Laughter ]
-People call me "Deeves."
Call ma Deeves.
How about Ma Deeves?
-Ma Deeves?
-Yeah. Ma Deeves.
Madea. Madea.
-No! This is terrible.
-No. She's you're sister.
-Ma Deeves? Ma Deeves.
-Dever. How about Seesters?
-Seester?
[ Laughter ]
-"This is my seester."
Seesters is the name
of the band.
Like Friendster.
S-E-E-S-T-E-R. Seester.
-No "The."
-No.
-Just Seester.
-Seester. That's the name.
Congratulations.
-I'll run it by Maddie.
Thank you.
-Yeah, no problem.
-I'll run it by her.
-If you ever need my help...
[ Applause ]
You sing,
but you also play the guitar.
-Yeah.
-Do you remember your first song
you played on the guitar?
-It was "Crazy Train"
by Ozzy Osbourne.
-Wow!
-Difficult. Difficult stuff.
[ Imitating guitar melody ]
Wow.
-Yeah. That was good.
-Thank you.
Were you into heavy metal?
-I had a phase.
I had, like,
a Criss Angel phase.
I had, like, a real --
And I say it was a phase,
but then I go back and realize
that it was kind of a long time
that I liked these things.
-I want to talk about --
I wanna talk about "Dopesick."
-Yeah.
-This is based on a true story.
It's an insane story.
I know Michael Keaton
is a producer, as well,
and co-stars with you.
But it's basically
about the opioid crisis.
-Yeah, opioid crisis
that began in the '90s,
and we follow the Purdue Pharma,
Sackler family story line,
but we also follow
the doctors and victims
of the crisis, as well,
and it's --
-It's just a scary thing.
-It's really crazy.
-OxyContin.
It's like just, "Yeah.
Just get it. Just take it.
It's not addictive."
-But not a lot of people knew
about what was going on,
especially at that time.
But even now, like,
I have so many friends
that didn't know about,
like, the real truth.
And this -- our show is going
to reveal a lot of things.
-How was Michael Keaton
to work with?
-Ohh.
-Difficult.
-He's -- No, really
just the sweetest man.
He's truly, like,
a bucket-list actor for me.
I can't even tell you.
I mean, I've watched --
Obviously the classics
are, like,
"Batman," "Beetlejuice."
Everybody knows those, right?
The classics.
-Of course. Yeah.
-But what shaped me as a person
growing up was the film --
I don't know if you've seen
it -- called "Jack Frost."
-Wow! That's your
Michael Keaton go-to?
-That's my go-to.
-"Jack Frost" was --
-"Jack Frost."
-It's where he turned into
a snowman, right?
-Man turned snowman.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-With eyebrows.
-Did he get hit by a car
or struck by lightning?
-Michael Keaton eyebrows.
What?
-Did he get struck by lightning
or something?
-Yeah, it's --
-And he turns into a snowman?
-Yeah, you remember.
-Yeah, and he raises
his children as a snowman.
I kind of remember this,
but that's the one?
-Yes, you got to go back.
Skip "Beetlejuice."
Skip "Batman."
Go back to "Jack Frost."
-That's not true at all.
He's done so many great things.
You know what I love about him?
Is that he loves comedy.
He actually, like,
is a student of comedy.
He loves to do bits and --
-He was great. I loved him.
It's really shocking that
I'm in the same show as him.
It's really mind-blowing to me.
-Then George Clooney,
then Julia Roberts,
and now this.
-And now this.
-This is what I'm talking about.
Come on.
I want to show this. Hopefully
your seester's watching.
-[ Laughter ]
-Everyone, here is
Kaitlyn Dever and Michael Keaton
in "Dopesick."
Take a look at this.
-You're not the first person
who can't sleep
through the night.
That's not uncommon.
So, I got two options.
We can, uh, switch you
to a different medication.
-No, I-I don't want to switch.
This works better than anything
I've ever used before.
-Okay. Well, option two is
I can double your dose
to 20 milligrams.
But if that doesn't work,
I'm gonna switch you
to something else.
And, uh, if you're still
having a hard time
sleeping through the night,
you call me.
And if you don't call me...
-Then you'll call me.
-That's correct.
-Mm! Kaitlyn Dever.
"Dopesick" premieres
October 13th on Hulu.
Hi, Mom and Dad.
You've got to be very proud.